vulnerable uh will be brought back into
school at the start of the term so it's
uh
those are those proposals so they're
going further than just um
arguing with councils about whether they
should shut down early for christmas
yeah i think we're likely to get
something from matt hancock about that
in the chamber and there may be
something more official from dfe
uh about an hour or so later the reports
have been the sort of headline of what
they may announce or this hasn't been
confirmed yet
would be a delay in secondary schools
potentially going back um in january
we've seen this argument play out
this week between the secretary of state
and councillors in greenwich and south
london and islington and north london
who
moved to close down schools because they
said the public health situation
warranted it they were then threatened
with legal action from the department
for education
and then back down but it now seems that
perhaps
there might be some movement around
start dates in january
i think that would be a an interesting
move if they did it given the cast iron
guarantee
that the prime minister made um at the
beginning um
months ago now to keep schools open um
whatever
happens uh and i think if that happens
in parts of the country where bars and
restaurants are still open you might
hear some criticism that why are
schoolchildren not going back
when you're allowing bars and
restaurants just explain uh the delay in
this this was scheduled for half past
the hour but as we can see
um jacob rees-mogg is still answering
business questions in the week that's
when the house discusses
its business uh and um
obviously since he's announced just now
that this is the last day
of parliament possibly this year uh
although they may be recalled
uh if there is a trade deal to be agreed
uh clearly mps do have a number of
questions but also
fairly traditionally on these
end-of-year
occasions at christmas as we're seeing
that there's a certain amount of
jealousy
between the green benches although very
relatively few
people there uh sitting in the chamber
because
of the um social distancing
now i assume rob that when we do hear
from the health secretary matt hancock
he's going to announce tears which are
kind of going to last
up to the christmas period and then come
into force again
after that five day break yeah so it's
the next review point is in two weeks so
matt hancock will be announcing it that
will take us up to the end of the year
basically
but remember within that there is the
national five-day reprieve
um for christmas so this will go up to
christmas and then you'll have five days
where
in terms of restaurants and bars the
rules all stay the same
but it's mainly on the household mixing
that obviously changes across christmas
three households can mix
other than if you're in wales when it's
two households and an individual
and one single person um i think that's
why when the announcement was made for
london people were perhaps left
scratching their heads a bit because
london had gone from full lockdown
to tier two to tier three and then to a
five day reprieve and then back to tier
three
afterwards so there is a degree of
jumping around i think
uh that matt hancock will be hesitant to
make too many moves
i think for risk of really muddying the
message even they're just just uh
changing around the casting in the
chamber because of course people now
have to be designated to attend the
chamber because of social distancing and
should be a couple of minutes and we'll
be uh hearing from matt hancock one
thing that confuses me though
is there's always a certain amount of
suspense about these announcements
but at the same time you talk to people
in many parts of the country
and they say we already know what's
happening
well i think there is a degree of
confusion because the rules have changed
a lot and i think i think there may be a
degree of confusion around
bubbles and the use of bubbles obviously
you get a child care bubble you can have
a support bubble
but i think that is the risk really that
these tiers were brought in and this may
well be why this speculation around a
tier three plus or a tier four doesn't
come to pass
because what the government was trying
to do by introducing this three-stage
tier procedure
is to just simplify the rules to say
look this is what
the rules are we saw before lockdown
sort of customized tiering
extra things put in in certain regions
maybe gyms were closed or weren't closed
limits on off license sales
i think what they tried to do coming out
of lockdown was very much simplify it to
make it as simple as possible you've now
got a checker
on the app and on the website where you
can view your area and find out what
restrictions
um are are taking hold in your area and
i think that was part of the reason why
should they introduce rules for
christmas as well is the worry would be
is that people would basically see
relatives anyway and the risk is if you
start breaking the rules
over christmas you may be less likely to
follow them afterwards but if you give
them
a bit of wiggle room legally then people
are more likely to actually stick to the
letter
of the law now matt hancock has tended
to like to look on the bright side uh
making these announcements
was that the saying yeah but presumably
today
he's going to have to take his time from
the prime minister and just urge extreme
caution to people
yeah i think we did see a change of tone
um yesterday in that press conference
from the prime minister
whereas initially when the christmas
relaxation
was announced there was perhaps a degree
of um jolity about it all
what they're trying to do is not change
the rules but sort of massage the
message a little bit i think there'd be
mps that would say they should have
probably been striking that more
cautious
speakers taking his chair matt hancock's
in the chamber
uh replying to him will be john ashworth
labour's
shadow health spokesperson and looks uh
rob as if they are getting ready now uh
to have business this statement on the
tears from the healthcare social care to
make a statement
secretary hancock thank you very much mr
speaker
mr speaker as we enter the coldest
months we must be vigilant and keep this
virus
under control yesterday 25
161 cases were reported and there are 18
038 people in
hospital with coronavirus in the uk we
must
keep suppressing this virus and this
isn't just a matter of a government or
for this house
it's a matter for every single person
and these are always the most difficult
months for people's health
and for the nhs and especially with the
vaccine
already here we must be cautious as we
accelerate the vaccine deployment
as per the winter plan we've come so far
we mustn't blow it now mr speaker when
we reintroduced the tiered system we
resolved to review the data
every two weeks in each area
the sophisticated coveted surveillance
system we now have in place means that
we can act swiftly and decisively when
needed
at the weekend we held an emergency
review for london essex and parts of
hertfordshire
where accelerate where cases are
accelerating fast
yesterday we held the first formal
review
and i must report to the house that
across the world
cases are rising once more in europe
restrictions are being reintroduced
in america case rates have accelerated
in japan
cases are rising once again yesterday
the welsh government made the decision
to tighten restrictions across the whole
of wales
no one wants tougher restrictions any
longer than necessary
but where they are necessary we must put
them in place
to prevent the nhs from being
overwhelmed and protect life
mr speaker even in a normal year this is
the busiest time for the nhs
as chris hopson the chief executive of
nhs providers reminded us this morning
controlling infection rates is about
limiting patient
harm and this is a moment when
we act with caution in the southeast of
england cases are up
46 in the last week hospital admissions
are up by more than a third
in the east of england cases are up
two-thirds in the last week
and hospital admissions are up by nearly
half
it is therefore necessary to apply tier
three measures
across a much wider area of the east and
south
east of england including bedfordshire
buckinghamshire
berkshire peterborough the whole of
hertfordshire
surrey with the exception of waverly
hastings and rother on the kent border
of east sussex and portsmouth
gospel and haven't in hampshire
these changes will take effect from one
minute past midnight on saturday morning
and i know that tier three measures are
tough
but the best way for everyone to get out
of them is to pull together
not just to follow the rules but do
everything they possibly can
to stop the spread of the virus where
we've seen
places get the virus under control and
come out of tier three
it's where everyone has taken
responsibility on themselves to make
that happen
we've seen case rates fall across large
parts of england
and i know that many places in tier
three have seen their rates
reduce in most places i have to tell you
mr speaker we are not quite there yet
and the pressures on the nhs remain
but we are able to move some places down
a tier
we assess these decisions according to
the five published indicators
case rates case rates amongst the over
60s test positivity
rates of change and hospital pressure
and today i'm placing in the library of
the house an assessment of each area
and publishing the data on which we make
these decisions
for the vast majority of places
currently in tier three
we're not making a change today however
mr speaker
i am pleased to say that some places can
go down a tier
in bristol and north somerset rates have
come down from 432 per 100 000
to 121 and falling and i can therefore
announce that bristol and north somerset
will come out of tier 3
into tier 2 on saturday rates in
herefordshire
have also come down to 45 and 100
000 and are falling and we can therefore
bring herefordshire out of tier 2
and into tier 1. i want to pay tribute
to everyone who's been doing the right
thing and getting rates down
whether or not your area has come down a
tier today
it's so vital that everyone sticks at it
and does the right thing
especially over this christmas period
and it's important to remember that this
can be a silent disease one in three
people
who has the disease has no symptoms but
can still pass it on
everyone therefore has a personal
responsibility
to play their part in keeping this
pandemic under control
i know that other areas are so eager to
move down tears
and the best thing we can all do is act
with responsibility to get the virus
under control
mr speaker these restrictions are
thankfully not the only tool we have now
to fight the disease
we're further expanding our testing
program and later today the education
secretary will set out
further action on school testing in the
new year
and of course the vaccine rollout is
accelerating
i can update the house that over 200
vaccination sites are now
open in all parts of the uk with more
opening their doors
and bringing hope to communities over
the coming days
and i know that everyone will be as
thrilled as i am every time they're
contacted by
a friend or a loved one getting the jab
it was a wonderful sight to see
the global map of vaccine deployment
with the uk
proudly standing out as the site of the
first vaccinations
it's a huge logistical challenge but the
vaccine offers us promise
of a better year ahead and until the
great endeavor
of vaccine deployment reaches enough
people to make this country safe
we must keep doing what it takes to
protect our nhs and protect those we
love
that means all of us doing our bit
following the rules and taking personal
responsibility
to help contain the spread of the virus
so we can
get through this safely together and i
commend this statement to the house
i now call the shedder secretary of
state jonathan ashwin
well mr speaker and i thank the
secretary of state for advanced site of
his
uh statement these past 12 months have
seen covert spread with
speed and severity over 65 000 have died
in the united kingdom at least 620 of
them health
and care workers making the ultimate
sacrifice in the line of duty
over 240 000 have been treated
in hospitals with the disease and as the
secretary of state
reminded us what gives this virus such
lethal advantage is that people who
appear healthy
can go about their lives unaware they
are
transmitting the virus to others so of
course we accept and understand why he's
had to move
areas into higher tiers today even
though this means
tens of millions of people across
england are now
living under the toughest restrictions
and we're grateful that he's placing in
the library
uh details on each of our local
authority areas
but two weeks ago he did say that
we have the virus under control and he
also said
we can't risk letting cases rise again
especially into christmas but i'm afraid
that is exactly
what is now happening isn't it yesterday
england reported over 23 000 cases
the highest numbers in a month hospital
admissions on 14th
december were the highest since 16th of
april
the number of people in hospital with
covid is now the highest
since the 22nd of april the number has
risen 20
percent since the end of lockdown if it
goes up by another 20
we are back at the same peak we saw in
april
these numbers should be sounding all the
alarm bells there
are and it's why clinicians are pleading
with him
to put robust arrangements in place to
keep people safe
through christmas we saw in canada and
in the us huge spikes and infections
following the thanksgiving we will see a
spike here
this isn't about cancelling christmas
santa will still deliver his presence
but is he really telling us that
allowing
allowing indoor mixing of three
households across regions and
generations for five days
is sensible given the virus is raging
with such
ferocity at the moment and the
devastating tragedy is
that those who will be most impacted by
the survivor spreading through the
easing
are those who will be at the front of
the queue for the vaccine
in the next month or two so will he look
again
at the christmas arrangements on
vaccination with more than 130 000
vaccinated in the first week that is a
good thing and we celebrate and
and we congratulate all involved but to
vaccinate every older person vulnerable
person and key worker by easter
will need to do something like double
that every day
the national audit office this week said
11.7 billion for the program will be
needed alongside 46 000
extra staff so how much is actually
allocated to the vaccine program at the
moment
and how many staff have been taken on
and trained to support the vaccination
program
and when will we see the mass
vaccination centers opened in our
constituencies
there have also been warnings today
about vaccine rollout and primary care
taking longer than planned because
existing software systems keep crashing
the system doesn't alert gps if a
patient on their list
has already had it in the hospital and
gps are forced to turn to pen and paper
for data capture
so when will there be a national call
and recall system
for gps and why wasn't it ready for the
rollout this week
he mentioned the secretary of state for
education is to make a statement on
schools i don't know if that means he's
coming to the house or not but
with schools going back in january can
he provide some clarity around
testing in schools because there is some
speculation
that the opening of schools will be
delayed by a week in january
could he give us an update on what is
happening on that front
finally mr speaker madam deputy speaker
this has been a
dismal year for our national health for
all of us but our national health
service workers and our
care workers have as always done us
proud
so can i put on record my thanks to all
of them many of whom will be working
through
the christmas and new year period and
can i also thank all those working on
the response to covert his departmental
officials our medical science community
our public health teams
as well and with that can i wish you
madam deputy speaker
and all working in the house and indeed
the secretary of state
a safe christmas and a happy new year
secretary of state
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
well the uh the honourable gentleman
uh rightly asks about the uh
arrangements
in place for christmas which the prime
minister set out
yesterday very clearly
christmas is a very special time of year
and that's why we've put in
these arrangements that we have and it
is a matter of people's personal
responsibility to ensure
that they they act and they see their
loved ones
in a way that is safe and careful and i
think people understand that
and i what's more i think people will
abide by it
we know that it is safer to see older
people
especially if they're over 70 or
clinically extremely vulnerable
if you've taken the care to reduce
social contact beforehand
and we also know that after christmas
being able to reduce social contact will
be important for keeping this
under control and i think that aspect of
personal responsibility is important
sometimes in this house it feels to me
like the debate is
is as if if we don't in government put
in place
concrete rules then nobody will take any
action actually
it's down to individuals each and every
one of
us to take responsibility for our
actions
within the rules of course but also
being cautious this is a massive team
effort and it is
my experience of the last few months my
experience of the last few months
is that when a community has come
together to get case rates down
that is when it has happened and when it
has worked and
even with the rules in place it is only
when the community essentially comes
together to
to get this under control uh that you
you get the uh
you get the cases coming down and the
pressure on the nhs i regret having to
take the action
that we have to take i deem it necessary
and there's a a strong view right across
government
that these actions are necessary but i
also
plead that personal responsibility
is absolutely central to how we as a
society
should respond to this this uh this
pandemic
he asked about the mass vaccination
rollout the mass
vaccination sites are appropriate for
the
uh for the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine should that come through and be
approved by the regulator
and so it i it is some weeks until we'll
see those
uh those rolled out however we are every
day
having more and more primary care sites
coming on board
with the with the rollout of the pfizer
vaccine
and it's very good to see that uh
happening and i expect the numbers
that are vaccinated to to accelerate the
admit the team have made a very very
good start
and there's a lot a long way further to
go he asked about the data systems the
data systems have
uh very largely been working uh very
effectively
of course any very large logistical
organization
but they are small and been brilliantly
dealt with
locally on the ground uh he asked about
the rollout of testing in schools
as i say the education secretary will
set out m more
uh details about offering all secondary
schools colleges special schools
and alternative provision settings the
help support and facilities to test as
many secondary age and fe
students as possible as they resume
their education
in january and i think in advance
all of the work of teachers and support
staff in schools
who will no doubt lean in
and support this task to make sure that
school return can be done
as safely as possible and finally may i
echo the words of the honourable member
and wish him
a happy christmas and a safe christmas
and look forward to i look forward very
much to seeing him again in
and january we go to the chairman of the
select committee
jeremy hunt thank you madam deputy
speaker in the last week i've received
unexpectedly joyful emails from
residents of southwest surrey
who have been amongst the first in the
world to receive
a clinically approved vaccine for
coronavirus so can i thank him for that
early
christmas present and also thank him for
the
energy the endless media rounds and the
dedication that he has shown in the last
year which must be one of the toughest
imaginable for a health secretary and
i'm also grateful that
waverly has been excluded from the
surrey-wide move to tier three in
recognition of our lower
infection rates although we will remain
vigilant
i want to ask about christmas just a
week away
of course personal responsibility
matters
but in a pandemic so does clarity so
irrespective of the law or the
regulations
should we or should we not have indoor
social gatherings with elderly and
vulnerable
family members madam deputy speaker
people should act with great caution
and people should act with great caution
in this pandemic
because it protects them it protects
their families it protects
their loved ones we've set out what the
rules are but they are not a limit
up to which we should all push we can
all
act within those rules to limit the
spread and by
reducing social contact uh in the
in the days up to a meeting
a family member who may be
for instance over 70 or any other um
family member
it is reasonable and responsible to
to to take that sort of action i'm very
grateful for what he said about
um about the vaccine rollout uh that it
it is it is uh i i've been cheered by
messages
i get from constituents and others uh
now that they're receiving the vaccine
and uh we've just got to make sure we
get this deployment
out as fast as this as the vaccine
can reasonably be produced and as fast
as the nhs can
deploy it so that we get people the
safety of that vaccine
and so we can get through this and out
of this as soon as possible
now we go to scotland to the snp
spokesman martin day
thank you madam deputy speaker it is
important
that the festive days ahead do not
become a five-day math get together
therefore we should use as little of the
flexibility as possible
spread over several days while ensuring
that no one is facing christmas alone
the concerns from medical professionals
that the christmas covered
restriction relaxation will cost lives
are not to be dismissed
lightly and would the minister agree
with me that if people
are to form a bubble that it should be
kept as small as possible
and if so would it not be better to
follow the scottish approach
which sets a strict maximum limit on the
numbers of up to eight people from three
households
rather than the potentially unlimited
numbers permitted currently in the
english bubbles
well this has been an incredibly
difficult year for so many people and
for so many families
and the fixed numerical limits
uh have a particular burden on very
large families
uh and so we have taken i think a
balance and the right approach
but madam deputy speaker i understand
the urge
for caution of course i understand that
from my nhs uh colleagues and
others but madame definitely speaking i
also understand that people want to see
their children
who want to see their loved ones and
christmas is an important time of year
and we've got
to find balance suburna jenkin
good man deputy speaker and may i join
with my rightful friend and wishing our
nhs staff and everyone in this crisis uh
a happy christmas but we also join with
me in
wishing the essex county council and
local authorities in essex
uh a happy christmas what they're now
contributing to the test track and trace
operation since the
nhs tests and trace started to share
data
much more quickly with local authorities
can i report to him that
most districts have now started door
knocking to follow-up
contacts and case cases and the complete
case and contact rates are
now around 87 percent and 90
respectively
uh would you join with me and
congratulating local authorities in
essex on this tremendous effort
my right over is absolutely right and
i'm grilling because i think this is the
first time of the
dozens and dozens of statements i've
done this year when the honourable
member opposite hasn't mentioned
track and trace and i'll tell you why
madam deputy speaker
it's because the latest statistics show
that where communications were available
96 96.6 of people were reached and told
to self-isolate and that's because of
the huge improvements in contact tracing
and in testing that have been delivered
this year including
including of course with local authority
partners
but also with the brilliant national nhs
test and trace system
which we should all which we should all
congratulate
i think that getting those contact rates
i
think getting those contact rates order
order
this is not a moment for shouting
listen to the secretary of state i think
i think the moment
when we see contact rates over
90 should be a moment when everybody
should come together and say thank you
and well done to everybody at nhs tests
and trace and
all of their partners whether they're in
the public sector
or the brilliant private sector partners
who we all support
now we're going to bradford to judith
cummings
thank you madam deputy speaker and happy
christmas to you and yours
the secretary of state will know the
significant effect the pandemic has had
on nhs
dentistry there is a backlog of more
than 19 million appointments
it is therefore shocking and
unacceptable that nhsn
england has just decided to impose a new
activity target
on dentists in england which many will
simply not be able to meet under new
covered restrictions
nhs england's own data shows that nearly
60 of dental practices
will be hit with severe financial
financial penalties
dentists will now need to prioritize
check-ups rather than dealing with a
backlog of patients
needing treatment others may be forced
to close entirely
a straight choice between staying
financially viable or treating those in
pain
with more complex problems will the
secretary
of state reverse this decision which
threatens patient safety and access
and could lead to the demise of nhs
dentistry
as we know it uh madam deputy speaker i
i'm i'm very glad to be able to reassure
the honourable lady
that uh this agreement that has been
reached with the dentists
is all about making sure that whilst we
support our nhs dentists
we also of course want to see them
doing as much as they can to
to look after people and to get the
treatments that they need so this is a
good balanced program
and i'm sure it will be implemented well
by the dentist
dr liam fox thank you madam deputy
speaker may i say how delighted i am
that north somerset
is moving down into tier two which is
just reward for the efforts
of my constituents and the whole
community in the measures they've taken
and also
offers great potential help for our
hospitality industry
as we go into the christmas period and
on the question of balance can i
completely agree with my right
honourable friend it's not just about
the number of people
and the number of households it's also
about the age and vulnerability
of those who are meeting that we have to
consider and can i just say
in uh echoing uh words of one of my my
colleagues
a very happy christmas to my right one
friend and his team of ministers
who have done the most difficult job
imaginable
in a rather exceptional way and we hope
that
but not in much expectation that they
get some break
over the christmas period and thank you
very much madam deputy speaker well
the the the people of uh of north
somerset
who he represents uh and also of um
uh nearby western superman uh have
have done a remarkable job in bringing
the case rates down to as i say to 120
over in for every hundred thousand i'm
very pleased
that there that we're able to take north
somerset out of tier three
into tier two but i would also say to
everybody
that the point about personal
responsibility uh which he stressed and
i strongly agree with it still applies
because coming out of a tier does of
course make life easier and we don't
want these tears in place longer than
absolutely necessary but it is still all
on
everyone in north somerset to do their
bit and in in bristol and herefordshire
which have also come down
um to do their bit and to uh and to keep
those case rates down
and now we go to hull to carl turner
thank you madam deputy speaker the lead
up to christmas is the busiest period
for hospitality businesses with some
pubs in my constituency
making up to a quarter of their annual
profits which are now
lost if measures to control the viruses
to be effective
they must go hand in hand with proper
business
support to protect lives and livelihoods
what's he going to do to make sure
businesses forming the backbone of my
communities in hull get the financial
support
they desperately need
well i i'm i i i think that
everyone in hull should feel
um i i feel gratitude to them for the
work that they've done to get case rates
down as far as they have
um hull has done well along with the
rest of the humber area but we're not
quite there yet
um and so we are putting the support in
that comes with being
a part of tier three we've put record
sums in to support hospitality but i
appreciate this is tough especially in
the run-up to christmas
so i'll i i can commit to keep working
with the honorable gentleman
and with other colleagues across whole
humber the other areas that are in
tier three to do everything we can to to
get the hospitality open again
kate griffiths
thank you madam deputy speaker i want to
pay tribute to the work of staffordshire
county council in rolling out rapid and
large-scale asymptomatic community
testing
in my constituency of burton and
newtoxitter the director of health has
raised a number of concerns with the
department about the lack of clarity
over funding
for these tests will my right honourable
friend review the three letters that
have been sent to his department on this
issue
in order to provide the clarity which is
urgently needed to allow this testing to
continue
yes i'll get on to it right away i'm
really glad that uh
staffordshire have done such a they've
really
worked hard on getting this community
testing going
uh stoke-on-trent was the one of the
first places in the country to get going
on it and now
we've spread it out to wider in staffs
i'll absolutely pick up the point
that she raises and i'll get back to her
straight away
stir creasy
thank you madam deputy speaker the
secretary of state
tells us about personal responsibility
does he recognize that he has a
responsibility to be honest with the
public about what is happening
as well this week wips cross hospital
had to turn away ambulances because the
icu was full
as a direct result of the rising coveted
infections
in our local community and the hospital
had to move to early discharge of
patients
the secretary of state says he's
publishing data will he commit to
publishing real-time data
about a e fire breaks icu capacity
and what elective surgeries are and are
pla
plan surgeries have been cancelled by
hospital
so the public can see the truth about
why and how we need to protect the nhs
and what impact it has on their health
outcomes
well madam deputy speaker the honourable
lady is absolutely right about the
impact of the virus on the nhs in
her part of the world in northeast
london whips cross hospital
is under significant pressure the case
rate in her waltham forest
local authority is 431 per 100
000 we've got to work together to get
the cases down especially
in east london where it's very very
significant and we publish a huge amount
of data
on the hospital admissions and the
impact
on the nhs and i'm publishing further
data on this today and putting it in the
library of the house
felicity thank you madam deputy speaker
i'm glad to see that three areas are
coming down a tier and i think that is
vitally important
for compliance going forward because the
general public
needs to see that if they do follow the
rules
get their cases under control then there
will be payoff
does my right honorable friend agree
with me that what is important is
complying with existing restrictions
rather than ever more severe
restrictions and it is
critical that we take the public
including the young
with us i agree with every word that my
uh honourable friend has just said i
strongly agree
that the best way to get out of tier
three is by
by everybody coming together to comply
with um restrictions but not just to
comply with them because they're the law
but to take that responsibility
to ensure that we don't spread the virus
which each one of us unwittingly can do
because of its asymptomatic nature
so i thank my honourable friend for her
question
and and also for the message that it
sends that you can
we can get areas out of tier three we
can get areas out of tier two
into tier one we've gotta all work at it
monira wilson madam deputy speaker i
asked the secretary of state
uh via a written question the estimate
his department had made
of the proportion of the population not
registered with a gp
to which the answer was no such estimate
has been made
i found this concerning given how
important gps are
to the roll out of the clover 19 vaccine
not least for vulnerable populations
such as the homeless and those who move
around
a lot so could the secretary of state
please explain
what plans and provisions are being made
to ensure the vaccine is available to
those who aren't registered with gps
the honorable lady raised an incredibly
important point because
it doesn't matter whether you're
registered with anybody or not
you can still spread the disease
and and so the reason for the answer
that she states
is that um we is that we we
have to try to get the vaccination
program out to everybody no matter their
status and there are people who
who don't have any um status in
paperwork are tall and we need to make
sure that we support the rollout to
them as well and we're working with the
communities department
who are best placed along with local
authorities uh to
to do this um and uh to make sure that
the vaccination
reaches anybody who fulfills the
criteria set out by the
the joint committee on vaccinations and
immunization
mark harper thank you very much madam
deputy speaker can i um welcome the fact
that gloucestershire is remaining in
tier two can i thank the secretary of
state for
the engagement he had with me and my
gloucestershire colleagues
this week uh very much appreciated and
it was a very much a
team effort to get to where we are can i
press him a little on what he said about
vaccines in the
data that's going to be published from
next week
and can he confirm that it will have
enough detail in it so that we can see
clearly the vaccination rollout by age
and by area and can he set out early
when we return in january the
government's thinking
about how far the vaccination program
needs to have gone
the level of risk we will have reduced
the country by so that we can start
releasing the restrictions
that are so burdensome on our population
yes we're committed to setting out uh
weekly
updates on the vaccination program uh
the first data we released obviously was
yesterday the hundred and thirty to
seven thousand
um and also increasingly in the sorts of
breakdowns
that he asked for um as the
um as more and more groups are are
reached
and the calculus that he asks for in
terms of the proportion of the
population who need to be
uh to be protected in order to be able
to bring down
restrictions is exactly how we are
thinking about the next
phase we don't yet know uh
the impact because of the vaccine on
transmission
and therefore we can't have yet a
concrete answer to his question
but it's the question it's precisely the
question that we're asking
and within the next few weeks we should
know much more
chris stevens thank you madame dave to
speaker our recent studies have shown
that
vaccine hesitancy is highest among the
brain community and low income groups
with the real fear
that these groups have been deliberately
targeted with misinformation so can a
secretary of state
tell us how his department is going to
counter this so that people can make
strong choices
and turn and to avoid covert health
disparities going forward
yes he's quite right to raise this and
um we
in fact i was talking about the
vaccination program to my um
to the snp health uh cabinet secretary
only this morning
uh because making sure that we reach all
who need vaccinations according to
clinical need is absolutely critical
but also then persuade them to take the
vaccine so there's a huge amount of work
on
on on tackling misinformation the most
important thing is to have the positive
information out there and i want to
thank all those
who have gone public with their vaccines
so far
we all saw um sir mckellen i thought a
wonderful
photograph i want to thank crew leath
who went public with her
vaccination um it's um it's absolutely
terrific
seeing people uh celebrating the fact
they're getting uh
vaccinated and um and therefore
encouraging other people
to do the same so graham brady thank you
madame definitely speak can i tell my
right honourable friend the statement
will be greeted with dismay
in greater manchester uh where we have
had severe
restrictions for nine months where in
nine
of the ten boroughs rates are below the
national average can i tell him as well
that my constituents have behaved
responsibly and that our rates are lower
than they are
in neighboring warrington or in
neighbouring cheshire
which have been put into tier two and
are also lower than they are in bristol
uh which has been moved from tier three
to tier two uh today
what exactly do we have to do to be
moved out of tier three
deputy speaker i understand my my right
honourable friends um
disappointment at this decision we look
very closely at
trafford at stockport at tameside
at nearby high peak and
at the prospect the proposal uh
to take a different decision for them
with respect to their near neighbors
um the challenge is that each time that
we've done that in the past we've then
seen
cases rebound and there continues to be
significant pressure on the nhs
in the northwest including in manchester
so i know that my writing
friend and i um have um have proposed
different approaches
uh on this on this one
um and i look forward to working with
him and
people right across manchester and to
get this sorted
rachel hopkins thank you madam daity
speaker
we need to make sure that schools
continue to be a safe environment for
students and staff and i'd like to take
the opportunity to thank
all school staff and head teachers
across luton who've done so much
to make their schools as coveted secure
as possible
i note the point made by the secretary
of state around the announcement
later around testing in schools but will
the government be publishing the
evidence to support the use of lateral
flow tests
for serial testing of students as this
is outside of the licensed use and
requires a change to the legal duty to
isolate
we're we are working on exactly that
proposal because the need to
use testing and use the easily available
and rapid return
lateral flow devices is incredibly
important they have an
important role to play being used in the
right settings
in the same way that the pcr tests have
an important role to play but it takes
longer to get the result back
so i look forward to working with her
with luton council and all those across
bedfordshire
to try to get this sorted clearly case
rates in bedfordshire are
shooting up very very in a very worrying
way
and i i thank her for her um
for her efforts and her public health
messaging to say to everybody right
across bedfordshire including in luton
let's work together to get this sorted
greg clark
thank you deputy speaker uh i i asked my
honourable friend to consider
restrictions on a more local level than
county-wide and i'm grateful
that he's done that across the country
today uh infections
in tunbridge wells whilst much lower
than the the average for the county of
kent as a whole
are nevertheless rising and there is
pressure on the local nhs
so i understand why there is no change
from tier three today
but will the secretary of state commit
to apply the five tests
fortnightly and to reduce our level of
restrictions
as soon as they're met and will he have
a word with the chancellor
to see what extra support can be given
to businesses in the hospitality sector
who have just lost uh what is the most
important
uh part of the trading year in what has
been
a miserable year yes of course i will on
i and i'll talk to the chancellor about
the point that he raises of course we do
already have a significant amount of
support for hospitality businesses but i
understand how difficult this is
um on the point about looking at local
areas
absolutely we will look at local areas
and
we've demonstrated that in the decisions
taken today for instance just over the
border in east sussex we've
unfortunately had to put hastings and
rother
into tier three
tunbridge wells today has a case rate of
288 per
hundred thousand um and i would say to
everybody right across kent
that we really need to to act
with serious responsibility right across
kent
no matter which part of kent you're in
we have a very
serious problem in kent and the only way
that we can get it under control
is for people in kent to essentially
behave
as if they have the virus
and are trying not to pass it on to
somebody else
be really cautious in kent it is the
area of the country which has the
biggest problem both in terms of case
rates and in terms of therefore the
huge pressures on the nhs and kent i
want to thank everyone
working in the nhs and kent for what
they're doing and
we're we're putting in as much support
as we can and i look forward to working
with my right on
a friend and all colleagues from across
kent and of course the county council
the district councils
to try to get this under control other
parts of the country have done it
and brought the case rate down and some
so far that we've been able to take them
into
tier two i'm sure we can get there in
kent but we've really really got to work
hard to make that happen
kevin jones thank you mr speaker on
monday i asked the secretary of state
when care home residents in county
durham would
get the vaccine and he didn't answer the
question i've now been
contacted by gps in chest street in my
constituency
who were first promised the vaccine on
the 16th of december
this was then put back to the 21st of
december having done all the work to set
the hub up
they've now been told the vaccine will
not be available till the new
year so can the secretary say tell me
when residents in chester street and
markets just will get the vaccine
and can i just say to the secretary of
state i don't want hype
i don't want uh generalizations i just
want a straightforward answer for those
constituents
we are opening more and more gpe
vaccination hubs each day
and so the answer specifically on
chestnut street is
as soon as we practically can but it has
to be done in a safe way
and and that is out of
um my hands out of his hands um and it
is a
a it is an important operational
set of procedures that need to be gone
through to open these hubs it is
complicated
i will look into his specific example
i'll write to him with details
but he will understand as will i'm sure
the people of chester
street that we're we're trying to get
this vaccine rolled out as
quickly as safely possible but safely is
an important part of that
neil o'brien thank you madam deputy
speaker
can my honourable friend confirm that if
people in harbor and urban wingston
continue to drive down rates of
infections locally
the different districts and boroughs in
leicestershire can be put in different
tiers
if the data supports that and will he
join me in congratulating our local nhs
here in leicestershire
for the efficient way that they are
rolling out the vaccine across the
county
yes on both counts madame deputy deputy
speaker
we looked at leicestershire in great
detail and i wish that we could have
taken
some parts of the county out i would
have wished that we could have taken the
county and the city out of tier three
unfortunately the data didn't support
that conclusion
and i'm grateful to everybody across
leicestershire because i know this has
been a long hard slog in
leicestershire with measures that have
been in place for a long time
liz twist thank you madame deputy
speaker and can i start by thanking the
people
of my constituency and across gateshead
who have worked really hard
to get the figure down professor michael
marmot's covert 19 review published this
week
shows that this pandemic has only
exposed long-standing health inequality
particularly in the north public health
teams play a vital part in this pandemic
and our core to addressing those
longer-term health inequalities
what has the secretary of state done to
make sure that public health teams
are properly funded to address those
inequities
and can as professor marmot says build
back
fairer well we do we do
we we are absolutely determined to build
back better
and uh that in that will absolutely need
to involve
tackling long-term underlying health
inequalities
and there's a huge um
there's a huge program of work that's
going to be needed to do that
after they've been demonstrated these
inequalities have been demonstrated by
this uh pandemic people in gateshead
have done a great job of getting the
case rate down
as with other areas still in tier three
we're not quite there yet and i know
that my team and her local director of
public health have been talking
about about uh about getting gateshead
and the rest of the northeast
into tier two when we can and um i
i hope that we can we can do that but
for now
let's be cautious let's keep this under
control
julian sturdy
thank you madam deputy speaker there
will be naturally disappointment across
yorkshire
as many areas stay in tier three
and i appreciate that york's tier
position will obviously be affected by
the current virus
picture but can i ask the secretary of
state which of the five
criteria the city of europe will have to
improve on to stand a good chance of
moving down a tier
at future reviews and will this depend
to a significant extent on how our
neighbouring local authorities perform
against these five criteria
well we do look at those human
geographies because many people commute
from
north yorkshire into york but york
and in fact many of the local
authorities around it have done an
absolutely fantastic job of bringing the
virus under control
in york the coast rate is 65 per 100 000
a little bit higher than we typically
take places into
uh tier one uh for instance
herefordshire is 45
which is the same level cornwall was
when it was put into tier one
um but it's moving in the right
direction the over 60s case rate is also
low
and the um there has been some pressure
as he knows on the hospital uh but that
is abating
so york and large sways of north
yorkshire are moving in
the right direction and um i would urge
everybody right across north yorkshire
to stick at it
barbara keely thank you madam deputy
speaker the secretary of state will
remember that he has agreed to meet me
and my constituent kelly shears
in order to discuss the issues that she
has had accessing cancer services during
the pandemic
during the pandemic kelly worked on the
front line with her ambulance service in
greater manchester
despite her history of breast cancer but
she couldn't have her check up a
mammogram when it was due
when she did have it the cancer had
returned and spread to her bones
she is now having chemotherapy and may
need surgery
i understand the social estate has many
demands on his time
but can he ensure that this meeting is
able to go ahead in early january as
these matters are time
sensitive yes yes i can i'm very sorry
that meeting hasn't happened yet and
we'll get right on to it for early
january
richard fuller speaker the changes
announced by my own friend for bedford
will be disappointing to residents and
businesses but i think it will be
helpful for them to understand that that
my right-hand friend is setting up the
tier system
established clear criteria and is
publishing the data and has said that he
will
be open to regular reviews but on those
criteria and benedict speaker when it
comes to the issue of hospital pressure
on the nhs
that is not a data-driven uh criteria
it comes with statements that the nhs is
under considerable pressure which is
very difficult for people to understand
because we always hear
pre-covered times and times now that the
hospitals are under pressure
so will my rival friend commit to
uh producing projections of occupancy
rates and acute bed occupancy rates
across the nhs and if possible down on a
hospital local hospital system basis
uh yes we are working exactly on how to
demonstrate that in a numerical rather
than a
narrative form um not least for the
reasons that he
uh sets out uh yeah i'd say i'd say to
him
that across bedfordshire we've seen this
very sharp rise in cases
especially in the more rural areas
actually
including northeast bloodfitcher so it's
so important that people across
meditature
take um take that personal
responsibility follow these new tier
three rules
and i hope that we can get it to come
down as fast as it's gone up
to b perkins
thank you madam deputy speaker people
across chesterfield will be very
disappointed that
with all the work they've done and with
chesterfield uh having lower
transmission rates and some of those
areas uh in tier two
that they remain in tier three and
they'll be particularly disappointed by
the health secretary's suggestion
that those communities who worked
hardest and been most disciplined are
the ones that are in tier two we know
that
uh isn't the case but doesn't the health
secretary realize
that if the government could offer a
support package that would support our
hospitality
sector if the government weren't at the
very last minute
announcing changes to our schools just
two days before the schools break up
there would be more credibility
to the sense it's personal
responsibility that's the problem here
rather than the ineptitude of this
government
no
sir edward lee um on behalf of my
radical friend for south hall in the
deepest can i thank the secretary of
state for
meeting us and promising that he will
adopt more granular approach and we can
assure him that we'll work hard in
linkage to try and get our tear down
and those are neighboring cities can i
also thank him and the prime minister
for resisting pressure from the
opposition
and from wales and scotland to change
the rules on
christmas this is entirely a right
approach and thank him for the
tone that he's adopted today that if
we're to defeat this it's a matter of
self-responsibility and personal
ownership of our health
right right well that's right and i
think that
you know we did look very closely at the
southern end of lincolnshire
which is a long way from where the rates
are incredibly elevated
um around uh lincoln and and
and the coast and west lindsay um the
um but unfortunately it wasn't possible
to bring
any of the lower tier local authority
areas in lincolnshire out of
tier three and unfortunately over the
border in peterborough we have seen a
very sharp rise
so we're not there we're not there yet
but i hope that we can
make significant progress especially if
everybody
listens to my right honourable friend
and takes personal responsibility for
their action
to try to do everything they can not to
pass this disease on
chuck drovie
madam deputy speaker jane roach is a
great champion of her community of
castlevale
her dad's vincent died of coldness
her sister jocelyn died five days later
of covid
they are two of the nearly 10 000 in the
west midlands who have died of koben
jane and her family are devastated they
agree for the
loss of their loved ones who will not be
with them this christmas
and she asked the secretary of state
this
why we had the highest number of deaths
in europe
can we be confident that lessons are
being learned that the mistakes made
will not be repeated
she asks uh when will the inquiry into
what happened over kovid be established
and crucially she asked will the
secretary of state
meet with her and other relatives of
those who have sadly died from across
birmingham
um yes madam deputy speaker i'm very
happy to meet with the honourable
gentleman
and constituents um to
to hear their stories many of us have
have have lost those close to us in this
terrible pandemic um we're um
we're constantly learning about how to
do things
uh better we're constantly learning more
about the disease
for instance the news earlier this week
about a new variant was because of our
surveillance system that we have to be
able to look out for changes
and then to try to understand them um
and so there is a
uh there are huge challenges as he knows
um but we
i i try to approach this always with uh
the view
of looking at how we can get the country
through
what is an incredibly difficult and
unprecedented time
with as few people as possible suffering
in the way that his constituent jane has
rob butler thank you deputy speaker
the news that buckinghamshire is going
into tier three
heralds the bleakest of midwinters
especially for local hospitality
businesses and it is imperative they get
extra help and that this lasts as short
time as humanly possible
given that stoke mandeville hospital is
currently under intense pressure
with many staff off sick either with
covered or self-isolating
it is alarming that buckinghamshire
healthcare trust currently has been
given
no date when it will get a supply of
vaccines
especially when they bring oxfordshire
is in a lower tier and does have them so
will my right honourable friend ensure
that residents and healthcare staff
can get the vaccine locally in
buckinghamshire
before christmas i'll write to him
immediately with the uh
with plans that we have uh for the
rollout
of uh primary care based vaccination
facilities
in um aylesbury uh
i regret having to put buckinghamshire
into these um
into the tier three measures but it was
unfortunately absolutely necessary on
the numbers
um aylesbury vale the local authority
area has a case rate of 235 and it's
rising really sharply
and my honorable friend set out the
challenges at stoke mandeville which is
an excellent hospital
but under significant pressure so um i'm
i'm glad that he understands why we've
had to take this decision
and i hope that across buckinghamshire
we can get these cases down and we can
get people vaccinated
as soon as possible jeff smith thank you
madam deputy speaker
the uh secondary schools in south
manchester are worried about the extra
pressure of running a mass testing
regime
on top of the contact rating they're
doing on top of the online learning
they're enabling and on top of their
normal
school everyday responsibilities we
really need to know what support they're
going to get to do the testing
so why isn't the secretary of state for
education coming to the house
to set out the plans and answer
questions as the secretary of state for
health rightly does
yeah well the secretary of state for
education will as he said be setting out
these
uh these plans we need we need to get
them out as soon as possible so that
people have got the last couple of days
of term
uh to work on them and um and he'll be
doing that look
i i testing in schools is incredibly
important it's going to become more
important as we roll it out more broadly
and i'm i'm really glad to hear uh some
of the statements from some of the
teaching unions about how enthusiastic
they are for
uh for testing especially in secondary
schools and
i'm sure that my writer and friend the
education secretary will want to work
with him
and others right across the country to
roll out this program
as effectively as possible and make sure
that we have high quality testing
in schools so that we can keep kids in
education as much as possible
and get the infection rate down by
finding those positive cases
and and and having them isolate william
rag
thank you uh madame it being christmas
and given the circumstances that we're
in
uh covid compliant carol singers in
stockport have been
heard to uh be sinking in the words that
well-known epidemiologist mariah carey
all i want for christmas is tier two but
sadly
uh in them in treating their outcome
hasn't been successful
at all so can my writable friend further
to
honorable friend the member for ultra
gum explain precisely what more
residents in stockport need to do in
order to regain
some of their some relative freedom
well yes we've got to keep getting the
case rate down in stockport it's
still over a hundred there's further to
go
um and right across greater manchester
and the surrounding areas i would urge
people
you know to do as they have been doing
because those case straights have come
down
really quite significantly uh and the
and the city
um right across greater manchester and
in stockport
people have been doing the right thing
but the pressures on the nhs remain
partly from people who are in hospital
with covert from when the rates were
really high
so i hope that we can make the move as
soon as possible and in the meantime i
hope that everybody has a
happy and safe and careful christmas in
stockport
ellie reeves thank you madame deputy
speaker
uk and eu pharmaceutical companies have
warned that no deal will lead to delays
of up to six weeks in obtaining vital
medicines
given the fisa vaccine is complex to
move and distributed from
brussels at minus 70 degrees does the
health secretary agree
that no deal would be catastrophic and
that everything should be done
to get a deal to protect our access to
vital medicines
we've got plans in place to ensure that
the vaccine
can continue to be distributed whatever
the
outcome of the discussions on a future
trading arrangement with the eu
robert hoffman thank you madam deputy
speaker
early this morning i visited a
vaccination center in harlow which is
running like a military operation
and has started vaccinating the elderly
and those in care homes
will my right honourable friend thank
west essex ccg
gp staff and volunteers who are
vaccinating many hundreds of harlow
residents
but will he also set out a route map by
which harlow can return to tier two
could i just ask him i will strongly
welcome the testing uh
announced for schools but can he also
confirm that school openings will not be
delayed in january
would um i i'm very grateful to what he
said about the vaccination
center in harlow it's a it's an
uplifting site visiting a vaccination
center
and um rarely have i seen so many smiles
on faces
in this year which has been such a
difficult year than when i visited
the the milton keynes vaccination center
last week and i'm i'm i'm really glad
that it's working well
in uh harlow i want to add my thanks to
his thanks for the
for the gps the volunteers the staff all
those organizing the
vaccinations in terms of a route map out
of
tier two of course in time the
vaccination program will help but for
now the best thing people can do
is to bring the case rate down by doing
everything they personally can
to not pass on this disease
unfortunately the case rate
is 302 per 100 000 in harlow with very
very elevated
a nearby epping forest unfortunately is
over 500
it is a very serious problem we've all
got to pull together to try to sort out
this this growth of the virus locally
um and that is the route to tattoo
can i echo to the secretary of state
what my honorable friend remember for
harlow said on on behalf of the people
of our community
thank you sarah owen
thank you madam deputy speaker
scientific advisors health care workers
and doctors have all warned that the
christmas season
will result in higher infection rates
the public aren't falls
and know that tougher restrictions will
likely be needed in the new year
will the secretary of state come out
with the obvious and admit now
that he will need to bring harsher
restrictions in january ending the
uncertainty faced by families and
businesses
or will he just allow these dangerous
mixed messages to continue from
government
where i agree with the honourable lady
is that the public artfuls
and the public know that
it is their responsibility as well as
the governments
to get this under control and that is
where the
emphasis on people taking personal
responsibility to ensure that they don't
pass on the
the virus this christmas that's where
the emphasis comes from
i think if you look at how the public as
a whole across luton
and across the whole country has behaved
during this this
this pandemic where we have these
restrictions that are so inimicable to
our
way of life that are unprecedented
but people have still followed them
because
they know that they're important and
that's the approach
that we're trying to take for christmas
um to make sure that we can keep this
this precious time of year but we can do
so in a way that's safe
jason mccartney uh thank you madam
deputy speaker
um i accepted kirkleese being in
tier 3 when we had some of the highest
coveted rates
in the country but cases have now
plummeted
and hospitalizations are down the case
rate in kirkleese
is around 167 below the english average
in my com valley constituency the case
rates are actually
under a hundred per hundred thousand and
therefore i
really thought we had a strong case to
be brought down
into tier two now look i appreciate the
secretary of state wants to be cautious
but can he tell me when will the next
review be
and really what more do my constituents
need to do to come out of tier three
madam deputy speaker legally there is a
review every two weeks but in practice
we
we review every week and i won't wait a
week longer than necessary to get
places out of tier three if we can
safely do that and to people across the
corn valley
i would say firstly that
the reduction in rates has been
impressive but we're not
there yet the pressure on the nhs has
reduced but is still significant but i'd
also say
to everybody in the corn valley that you
have a member of parliament who
probably talks to me about this more
than any other
in terms of making his case it isn't for
want of
effort from the local mp but this is the
decision based on the epidemiology and i
really hope we can get there soon
ferry o'clock
thank you madam deputy speaker madam
deputy speaker can i take this
opportunity to wish you
and the house staff a merry christmas
and a very happy new year
uh madam deputy speaker i've had
numerous emails from
unpaid carers uh in enfield north
concerned about access to
the vaccine can the minister set out
exactly when
unpaid carers would be given kovid 19
vaccine
given that they spend their time caring
for extremely vulnerable people and can
pass on this
could pass on the virus any guidance
will be huge comfort
to residents unpaid carers in enfield
north thank you
thank you the guidance has been set out
by the joint committee on vaccinations
and
immunisations i think it's very
important that we follow the clinical
advice in this prioritization to make
sure that it's fair
richard holden thank you very much
indeed madame deputy speaker
i'd like to thank the department of
health secretary of state for everything
they're doing
but i'm sure he'll appreciate like me
just how fed up my local hospitality
sector
across uh county german and northeast
are would you join me in thanking local
people for everything they're doing
because we have seen the case rates
really come down and also thank my local
nhs staff
who i saw when i visited on a night
shift a couple of weeks ago not only
giving care to people with kovid but
also
really showing love to them as they look
after them but will he commit to a
fortnightly review
will he ignore the la-7 and allow county
durham and perhaps parts of county
durham
to go a separate way if case rates come
down in the future could you update me
and write to me about the vaccine roll
out well he also pushed the
chancellor for extra support for my
local hospitality sector
yes of course madame deputy speaker i'll
write to him as soon as i can
on on the rollout of the vaccine
across his part of county durham making
sure that everybody can get access is so
important and hence we're taking this
community
led approach as well as the big hospital
sites
and the the truth is uh in county durham
we do look at county durham
on its merits on its own as well as of
course as part of the uh
um the the other northeast uh local
authorities
um and people in county durham have been
acting in a way that gets the case rates
down i'm very grateful
to them for doing that we're not quite
there yet and there is still that
pressure on the
on the nhs but we're moving in the right
direction
richard bergen
madden deputy speaker in the last 100
days
over 23 000 people in our country have
lost their lives
from kobed that scale of loss was
completely unnecessary
it's a result of a second wave caused by
this government
failing to put public health first we
know
the government ignored the scientists
advice in september
before that second wave hits and we know
that scientists
are warning that the current plans
including for christmas
are going to cause a deadly third wave
so will the secretary of state
come clean today and tell us how many
lives
the government scientists are warning
him will be lost
over the next few weeks under the
current plans
well the advice i have and the answer to
him is i hope as few as possible
especially as we get the vaccine rolling
rolling out but i just want to um pick
up something that he said about
about this pandemic this pandemic is
caused by the virus not by any
government around the world
it's caused by the virus and that's why
it's so important that we all come
together to try to tackle it rather than
trying to take this overly politicized
approach
so there's one swing his uh waitress
tested positive and so the proprietor of
the small cafe
closed immediately and went into
self-isolation
but test track and trace have not
contacted him
so he is without the wherewithal to
claim the allowance
can the secretary of state fix it
yes if he has the test reference number
i will
get onto it right away if nhs test and
trace has not
contacted the owner um it may imply
that he doesn't have to self isolate but
of course i'll want to look into the
details of the case before making such a
recommendation
i'll make sure that his constituents get
a full
clinically approved recommendation asap
barry gardner mr james canning became
our first doctor general in brent to
receive the vaccine earlier this week
whilst congratulating him and the
wembley practice team who delivered it
does the secretary share my concern that
care homes in brent have been advised
that the 970 doses that are
in the vaccine packs can't be split
because of the licensing conditions and
this means
that those who are over 80 in our care
homes
may have to wait until february or for
the
oxford vaccine before they get
vaccinated
if is this the case if so why
because it's hardly the protective ring
around care homes
that the secretary of state promised
well i'm very glad to say that we are
making significant
progress on tackling this uh this issue
the when he says it's a licensing
concern that doesn't
that shouldn't be read to imply that
it's some bureaucratic rule
it's about making sure that this is done
safely because if the vaccine
isn't delivered safely to the site then
of course
it isn't an effective vaccine and
therefore we are
taking it carefully to be able to
vaccinate
in care homes there has been some
vaccination in care homes
across the uk and so it can be done and
i hope that we can make
make good progress soon dr neil hudson
thank you madam deputy speaker i thank
my right umbra friend for the
reassurance he gave me last week about
the vaccine roll out to rural
communities
and will he join with me in paying
tribute to everyone in cumbria
and the wider uk who was involved in the
delivery of the kovid vaccination
program
and would you agree with me that the
best way we can build a positive 2021
is for people to actively take up their
invitation to have this vital vaccine
when it comes
and get their life-saving jab as soon as
it is offered
yes i couldn't agree with my honourable
friend more you know he knows
about uh about these things um and
he's exactly right that the best thing
that everybody can do is when the nhs
calls
take up that vaccine and get it done it
will protect them
and their community and help protect the
whole country and get us all out of
these restrictions
against which we choke wendy chamberlain
thank you madam deputy speaker yesterday
on college green i met with members of
the covid19 bereaved families for
justice group
and spoke with those who have lost loved
ones throughout the pandemic and will be
spending our first christmas without
them
they delivered a 200 000 strong petition
to downing street asking for immediate
public inquiry
in order to identify and learn lessons
now there has been an ongoing inquiry
the justice group have given evidence to
and that's been the coronavirus appgs so
can i ask whether the secretary of state
has read that group's interim report
and engaged with its findings
well i look at all these sorts of uh
reports and the team
in the department do to constantly try
to
learn uh given that this is an
unprecedented situation
uh all of the health authorities across
the uk
whether here or in edinburgh or cardiff
or
belfast we're always constantly talking
and trying to make sure that
all of the insights that can be gained
can be applied an example is
for instance the fact that we now have
contact tracing in the uk
up to reaching over 90 percent of
contacts that has been
due to the hard work and the improvement
and learning the insights
from each other about how we can make
the the systems better
bob blackman thank you madam deputy
speaker and i'm sure i speak on behalf
of the whole house
in thanking my right honourable friend
and his team
for all their hard work over the course
of this year
to combat this dreadful virus but also
for updating the house on a regular
basis
on what action is being taken can i give
him the opportunity then
to just reiterate the key message as we
approach christmas
that anyone who shows any signs of
having the virus
must get a test and if it's positive
must self-isolate
and not mix and mingle with people to
cut down on the spread of this
dreadful virus and also to think twice
before they mix with elderly relatives
if they have been in contact with anyone
who's had this dreadful virus well i
agree with every word that my honourable
friend has just
said over this christmas period i hope
that people
will yes take a moment to have
some some relaxation given especially
what a
tough your year it's been um to have the
chance to see loved ones but do so
carefully
knowing that one in three people who
have this disease
don't know that they have it because
they have no symptoms and so anybody
can be inadvertently passing it on to a
vulnerable
loved one and so therefore needs to be
very very careful
to reiterate that it is in the best
interest of everybody and their loved
ones and their community
to get a test at the first sign of
symptoms and testing is now
very very widely available right across
the country and and of course if the
test well matt hancock
making clear that the only areas that
will be if you like de-escalated from
tier three to tier two are bristol and
north
somerset and that's leading to a clutch
of conservative back benches led by
graham brady making it clear they were
extremely unhappy to
see that areas that had been suffering
restrictions for a long time had not
improved their situation more coverage
coming up top the next hour
you